[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
אבל יותר מתאימה לרמה של הליגה. אבל עדיין השאלות של רענן הם לא כאלה.
שוב, אני לא מאלה שקל לשאת דברים כאילו אתם זוכרים שאלה וזה לכל החיים.
זה לא מעניין שפתאום מעניין בלילה את אוהד ניגשת למחרת לעצב מחדש.
ב לא ישתתפו. אם אני לא יכול להגיד לך סורי, אתה ממש, אבל ממש משהו.
אם אתה מעל הכל לא יודע, לא כי זה או זה.
כמה זה 35 30. כאילו ממש אני יודע טוב ממני.
שאלתי אפילו את השם.
אבל התשובה. היא לא בידי אנשי לפיד הקמפוס נכנס.
הם שינו את דעתם. מאות שקלים, ביקשו לראות, יוצא ועדיין זה היה אז זה היה משהו.
אז זה נראה לי מעט אנשים מודאגים.
עד עכשיו היו לי רק שניים. זה?
כבר זמן מה אתה כבר מתחילה לספר לנו מה אני רוצה.
אז אני רוצה עמוס עוז שיכול להביא לך תואר ראשון.
אם היה לי מזל, אולי באמת חוץ מזה שאתה צריך גם להתחתן ולהביא את הזמן ביום שישי עוד שבת היה בסדר.
הוא מלמד מודלים ליצירת תמונות של מקור אחר מאשר כמה שיותר מהכל.
לא נהניתי כי זאת מתמטיקה שאני הבנתי ביום ראשון, ואז משוואה דיפרנציאלית לא רלוונטית או חזרה את המושג כאילו אנחנו לא כאילו למדנו מהדרים.
אבל מה זה מדען? אז זה ג'ון? זה הרעיון של המסלול הזה.
יש שם מצב שלומדים את זה? לא, אני מכיר, זה כבר הספיק להכניס.
יכול להיות שזה משהו ללמוד אותו? לא, לא.
אז אתם צריכים להגיד הנה סנדוויץ במונית.
אז כאילו תחשוב שאתה עושה מדע ביחד עם זה ויש לך כל מיני סוגים ואז אתה חבר לזה בשביל תחום ואז תחשוב שגם זה עניין גדול.
אבל אז עד הסוף זה לא קשה.
בכלל. אתה זוכר משהו?
אני זוכר שלמדתי לדבר. לא, לא לא לא, זה לא.
אני אמור לדעת איפה אמור? לשפר את הדברים?
זה לא משהו מסובך, ממש מסובך. זה אולי גם רוצה לפתור את זה.
ישר ולעניין הם מדברים.
שטויות. ואז בסוף בסוף משתלבים. זה שמציל את כולם זה פשוט מחבל בטעות.
אבל נניח שיש לך בן אדם מה? נכון?
למיכל עכשיו יש לכם הרבה זמן אז כאילו איך לא, אבל כאילו יוצאות לעבוד וכאלה כן.
כן. אז קודם כל אני אגיד.
אסכים. לקנות?
את? עד כאן מושלם.
בכל מקרה של פגיעה ברגשות הציבור שלא חושב.
כשאתה רואה את השקיפות, אף לא השאלה.
כל החשמל במחשב בכלל לא. לכאורה זה הזה הוא או מה זה חשוב.
יש דגש על מקום העבודה של מה הוא. עובד עובדת איפה?
אמרתי. לעצמי, מה זה משנה?
לא, לא, זה לא משנה. זה לא שאנחנו. חנויות הקצה של רשת.
איך אפשר? להיסטוריה יש מקום חשוב.
אז אני אשתמש בזה פשוט בגלל ההקלטה.
אז בעצם מה שסיימנו את השיעור הקודם זה בנקודה שהיינו רוצים.
פיצ'רים קצת יותר אבסטרקטיים מאשר פשוט הזהות של מילות ההקשר.
אז דרך אחת לעשות את זה זה בעצם להפעיל איזשהו סוג של הורדת מימד.
כן, איזשהו סוג של הורדת מימד. ובאמת היו לא מעט שיטות שניסו להשתמש ברעיון הזה, אמרו.
אוקיי. אוקיי, אני איכשהו.
בעצם מה שאני רוצה זה לקבל איזשהם פיצ'רים שלמשל אומרים משהו כמו במקום להגיד שקט הוא.
נגיד או שהיא מילה נתונה היא קול.
אוקיי? כן, יש לה הרבה הופעות משותפות, נגיד עם קאר ועם אוטומו ביל ועם string ווייל ועם אין ג'ין ולא יודע,
וכל מיני דברים מקני וכל מיני דברים שקשורים למכוניות, אני אפעיל איזה שהוא סוג של הורדת מימד ובשאיפה תייצר לי איזשהו פיצ'ר.
בעצם נכון, איזשהו פיצ'ר שמבוסס על המימדים הקודמים.
אולי אם זה ליניארי, אז איזשהו צירוף לינארי של המימדים הקודמים, שבעצם כל מופע משותף,
גם של אוטו רגיל, גם של המילה, נתונה עם אוטו מוביל, גם עם קאר, גם עם סטינג,
גם אם לא יודע מה מקליק, כולם בעצם יתורגמו בסופו של דבר לעליה בערך של אותו הפיצ'ר,
כן של איזשהו פיצ'ר משותף, וככה בעצם נימנע או נשיג איזושהי רמה יותר גדולה של אבסטרקטיות.
אפקט דומה שהורדת מימד תעשה זה תעשה איזשהו סוג של קלף סטרינג בעצם לקונטקסט words.
איזשהו string לכאן לקונטקסט words, כך שבעצם הקטגוריה של המילים שתיווצר או הפיצ'ר שיווצר אחרי ההורדות מימד ישקף קטגורייה ולכן מושג יותר יותר אבסטרקטי.
ובאמת היו שיטות לאורך השנים שעשו בדיוק את זה מי שמתעניין, אפילו טלי תשבי המנוח.
אני לא יודע אם הכרתם אותה. היה חבר סגל אצלנו במחלקה, נפטר לפני כמה שנים.
היה אחד מהחלוצים בתחום הזה ובאמת השתמשו שם בשיטות קלאסטר רינג יותר קלאסיות, כמו למשל כאלה שמבוססות על אס.
די. כן על סינגולר, ואליום, דיקור Position או שיטות אחרות.
וזה באמת הייתה גישה אחת שהשתמשו בה במשך הרבה מאוד שנים אם הכניסה של רשתות נוירונים, או בעצם כן כניסה יותר,
בוא נאמר מסיבית או החזרה של רשתות נוירונים להיות כלי עיקרי ב NLP בעצם שיפט קצת זז והוא פחות מבוסס על Speed.
לכן אני לא ארחיב את הדיבור על השיטות האלה, אלא אתמקד בשיטות יותר עכשוויות שנקראות בדרך כלל production base models.
אבל סך הכל שהרעיון שלהם הוא די דומה, הם עדיין מנסות לייצג את ההתפלגות של המילים המשותפות של ההופעות המשותפות של המילה הנתונה עם המילים האחרות בקורפוס,
והם גם מנסות לעשות את זה באיזשהו מימד יותר נמוך, כדי שה הפיצ'רים שייווצרו יהיו פיצ'רים יותר אבסטרקטיים מאשר פשוט הופעה משותפת עם מילה זו או אחרת.
אבל הם יעשו את זה פשוט בדרך קצת שונה של אופטימיזציה, שמה שבעיקר חשוב לי בללמד אותה זה זה לאו דווקא אני אלמד גם את הטכניקה עצמה,
אבל מה שיותר חשוב לי מהטכניקה עצמה זה בעצם הרעיון שנמצא מאחוריה,
כי אותו רעיון אנחנו בעצם נראה אותו חוזר עוד פעם ועוד פעם בשיטות העכשוויות ביותר בעצם שנגיע אליהם בהמשך הקורס,
שהם מה שנקרא קונטקסט של סקוואטים ספציפית,
אני אציג גישה שבעצם נקראת אסקייפ גם מודל מתוך החבילה המפורסמת של וואט ובק שנקראת וואט עובד של תומס מיכאלוב מ 2013.
ובעצם הרעיון שלה הוא שהוא שבעצם אם אני רוצה לייצג את ההתפלגות של המילים של ההופעות המשותפות,
של מילה עם מילים אחרות, דרך אחת לעשות את זה זה פשוט לאמן איזושהי רשת קטנה.
כן, שמה שהרשת הזאת חוזה זה את ההתפלגות הזאת.
כן, את התפלגות המילים, שותפות של מילים עם מילים אחרות בקורפוס.
ואז אם אני אסתכל פנימה לתוך הייצוג הפנימי שהרשת הזאת מצאה, הייצוג הזה יהיה איזשהו ייצוג של ההתפלגות הזאת.
בעצם כן הוא הוא יבטא באיזושהי צורה מקודדת.
כן את אותה אינפורמציה בדיוק, את האינפורמציה שהיא הפלט שאותו אני מנסה להשיג.
ולכן בעצם הרשת תלמד בשבילי מהי הדרך הטובה ביותר כדי לקודד כדי לדחוס את ההתפלגות הזאת באופן שאחרי.
זה יאפשר לי To דיכאונית כאילו לפענח את את הדחיסה.
כן, כאילו תדייק פרסית באופן מיטבי.
אז זה הרציונל. בואו נסתכל על הטכניקה ואז אולי נחזור לרציונל בסוף ונראה שזה מסתדר.
אז קצת מוטציה. אז עכשיו אני הולך בעצם להשתמש בסאב סקריפט כדי לציין את Types.
את Instant This Way Types, כלומר את הורדת from של איזושהי מילה.
זאת אומרת, פורץ על פני אחד עד גודל אוצר המילים איקס אחד נגיד זה בטא 2 זה X שלוש זה in וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
גודל אוצר המילים הנכון מסמן אותו בוי, כלומר אוצר המילים, מספר המילים השונות בצורת הצורה שלהם.
כן, בכתיבה שלהם, ואם גדול יהיה איזושהי פרפרה מתאר שאומר לי מה המימד של האם בדייג כן של הווקטור שאותו אני לומד בעצם,
לאיזה מימד אני דוחס את ההתפלגות באיזשהו אופן וזה ההיפר פרמטר.
עכשיו איך נראה מודל עסקי? גם בעצם הדיסקים?
גם יש לו צורה מאוד פשוטה. כן, אפילו לקרוא לו רשת זה קצת.
בוא נאמר קצת הפרזה, אבל בסדר. הרבה פעמים מציגים אותו ככה, אז גם אנחנו נשתמש.
הרעיון שלו הוא מאוד פשוט. סליחה,
אני עכשיו בעצם רוצה איזושהי רשת או איזשהו מנגנון שבהינתן מילה יידע להחזיר לי
את ההתפלגות של ההופעות המשותפות של המילה הזאת עם מילים אחרות באוצר המילים.
נכון, זאת המטרה שלי. אז איך זה יראה?
יש לי איזשהו input large שמה שהיא מקבלת זה פשוט one shot vector scale.
נגיד. עכשיו אני רוצה למצוא את ההופעות המשותפות שהמילה בעצם אני בודק ורואה שכורתים את המספר שלושים 1722 זה בעצם אז אני מזין את וקטור היחידה הזה.
אוקיי, אז בעצם אז מאזין לו וואן הוט? וקטור הוואן וקטור הזה כופה על מטריצה שבעצם השורות שלה הם כל אחת מהם בעצם מתאימה לאיזושהי מילה.
כן המטריצה הזאתי בגודל והגודל אוצר המילים כפול אין כשאין זה בעצם הגודל של ההיגד.
כן, הגודל של המימד שאליו אני מטיל.
אז יש פה איזשהו וקטור כלשהו ועכשיו הווקטור הזה הוא עובר מכפלה במטריצה נוספת, שונה מ דבליו דבליו תג, אבל המימדים שלהם הפוכים.
כן, עכשיו זה אין שורות ו V עמודות. ואחרי שאני מכפיל בעד שאני מקבל שוב משהו בגודל וקטור, בעצם מימד ציר V לא ואבין V כן, זה יהיה לכן.
שהוא בעצם ייצג לי את ההתפלגות, את תנאי השכנים.
עכשיו אתם יכולים לשער מה זה התפלגות על פני השכנים? זה לא בדיוק.
זה נכון. הרי סך הכל יש שם מספרים אולי שליליים, בטח לא שמסתכמים לך.
אז נכון, אז זה לא בדיוק הוואי עם האלה, אלא השופט מקס עליהם יתן לי את ההתפלגות.
אבל. סף מקס מכיוון שהיא פונקציה מונוטונית, נכון?
כאילו כל קואורדינטות, אם אני מעלה אותה זה גם יעלה את סוף מקס.
אז בעצם ה score הזה אפשר לחשוב עליו, כי בעצם כאיזשהו score של האסוציאציה בין המילה לבין מילת ההקשר.
אוקיי. יפה. אז כן, אז אפשר לכתוב את זה פורמלית.
מה שקורה זה ההתפלגות של השכנים.
של K כן, או שהמילה ה ג'יי תופיע.
תופיע כשכן השכנה של המילה k.
מה שצריך זה בשבילה לקחת את העמודה הרלוונטית, להזין בעצם את הוואן ואת וקטור את כשהוא חופן את המטריצה דאבל י דה פקטו.
מה שזה אומר זה שאני לוקח את השורה הרלוונטית מתוך המטריצה.
נכון, אני מקבל איזשהו וקטור. כן, השורה הרלוונטית הזאת זה איזשהו וקטור.
עכשיו אני בוחר את העמודה הרלוונטית מתוך Two prime רלוונטית, כלומר את באיזה אינדקס.
נכון, באינדקס עושים פה את המכפלות.
נעשה פה את מכפלה סקלרית, מקבל את Y, עושה לזה האקספוננט M.
כתבתי את זה במוטציה של MATLAB סתם כי לא, זה לא משנה.
הבנתם את הרעיון? לוקחים את העמודה, את השורה הקייט מכאן מכפילים אותה בעמודה Height.
מכאן מקבלים איזשהו בית. עושים את זה על פני כל העמודות האפשריות של דאבל יותר.
מקבלים הרבה מים ומפעילים על while soft max.
בסדר, כלומר לוקחים האקספוננט וממנו. ככה אני מקבל את ההתפלגות.
סך הכל מאוד פשוט. מה הפרמטרים של המודל הזה?
בדיוק המטריצות דבליו דבליו פאן. אוקיי.
כן. זאת אומרת השכנים של כל משפחת בעלך והזמנתי.
לא אז כאן שכן הכוונה היא ממש במובן של ההתפלגות.
בעצם אני עכשיו בונה ובונה רשת. שמה שהיא עושה זה בעצם דוחסת את ההתפלגות.
כן, אם אני מסתכל. זאת ההתפלגות שלי. זה עד כדי מנורמה לאחד.
כן, כאילו הוא מחלק את זה בסכום. אז הזה אני חושב עליו בתור ההתפלגות של הבסטה בקורפוס שפות.
ההתפלגות האמפירית כן של המילה בקטע בקובץ.
ועכשיו מה שאני רוצה לעשות זה לדחוס בעצם את הדבר הזה.
זה הרציונל. אני רוצה לדחוס את זה לאין מימדים.
אין גדול מימדים בעצם להוריד מימד לאיזשהו גודל אין, אבל בצורה שהיא תהיה סך הכל נאמנה למקור פחות או יותר זאת האינטואיציה.
כן, סך הכל אני רוצה לדחוס את זה בצורה בצורה אופטימלית.
ובעצם הפירוש של כל קואורדינטות כאן היא פשוט נגזרת מאיך הגדרתי הקשר.
אם הגדרתי את זה כמו כל המילים שמופיעות באותו המשפט איתה, אז זה הפירוש של הקואורדינטות הרלוונטית.
אם זה כל הבית כרמים שמופיעים לא זה סתם.
אני עובד עם בייקון כשר. אז כנל אם זה רק תת קבוצה של מילים אז כנל אם זה בחלון בגודל פלוס מינוס שבע מילים קדימה ואחורה וזהו.
אז לא משנה. אתה חופשי להגדיר את זה איך שאתה רוצה. הנקודה היא שברגע שהגדרת מה זה הקשר, הגדרת מה זה התפלגות לפחות ההתפלגות האמפירית.
ועכשיו מה שהרשת הזאת באיזשהי צורה זה זה מה שהיא עושה.
זה בעצם מטילה את זה או דוחסת את זה שתקרא לזה וקטור וגודל m.
וממנו ביקורת.
זאת ההתפלגות? כן, אבל זה פרשנות. מה שזה פקטור.
מה שהיא עושה זה בדיוק אותה נוסחה שכתובה עכשיו.
איך מאמנים את זה? אז בגדול כן, מה אעשה?
אבל בעצם אני מגדל אביב. אז הנה, אוקיי, אז עכשיו זה בדיוק זה.
אז איך בעצם אני מאמן? איך אני מעריך את הפרמטרים של המודל?
כן, דבליו דבליו, טג. אז מה שאני רוצה לעשות זה כרגיל.
אני רוצה לעשות משהו בכיוון של מקסימום likely. אולי קצת רגולרי.
זה ציה אחרי זה, אבל בגדול מקסימום לעיקריות. כלומר אני רוצה לקחת טקסט במקרה הזה קורפוס שעליו אני מבסס את ההתפלגות שלי, את שקודם חישבתי,
מנת ההתפלגות האמפירית ואני מנסה להעלות את ההסתברות של הטקסט את לוג ההסתברות של הטקסט.
עכשיו אני חושב במקרה הזה כל אוקיי, ההסתברות של הטקסט פשוט כמכפלה על כל הזוגות של המילים שאני מחשיב אותם או של מילה,
והקשר שאני מחשיב אותם כשכנים בסדר, וזה תלוי באיך שאתה רוצה להגדיר מה זה שכנים.
אם זה שתי מילים שמופיעות באותו משפט אז שתי מילים שמופיעות במרחק עד שבע אחת מהשנייה.
אם זה שתי מילים שמופיעות באותו מסמך פסקה מה שאתה רוצה.
אבל הנקודה היא שאני פשוט חושב על הטקסט בעצם כאוסף של זוגות של מילים.
הדבר המעניין כאן, וזה באמת הנקודה שבעיקר חשוב לי להבהיר זה שבעצם זאת בעיית למידה די משונה.
כן, זאת בעיית למידה די משונה, כי כי בעצם אנחנו כאילו עושים פה סופר ווייס learning.
נכון לוקחים. יש לי דוגמאות מילה ומילת ההקשר שלה.
יש לי לייק ליהוד או משהו כזה התפלגות של קורפוס ואני מנסה להעלות את ההסתברות שלה נכון.
לכאורה זה סופר ויסלר. אני כמובן לאומן, אבל בעצם אני א בכלל לא מתעניין בפרויקט סי הזאת למה שאני ארצה בהינתן מילה לחזות מי השכנה שלה,
אני לא אצליח דבר ראשון, כי כל מיני מילים יכול להיות. לא באמת מעניין אותי מי השכנה בעצם.
אני יודע שיש התפלגות. כלומר יש איזה שהיא שטוחה, סטיות אינהרנטית בתהליך.
אני מודע לזה. אני רוצה לקודד בעצם את ההתפלגות של המילה, אבל זה אתם אומרים.
מיכה בסדר, לפעמים יש כמה לייבלים, יש לייבלים מסוכסכים, אז זה עוד יחסית בסדר.
אבל הדבר שיותר נוצר בבעיית הלמידה הזאת זה שבעצם למה שאני בכלל?
למה שמישהו יתעניין בבעיה הזאת? כאילו יש לכם טקסט?
אם יש לכם טקסט אז תקראו את המילים בו. כאילו מה אתם בעצם אומרים לי אתם אומרים הנה תראו, יש לי טקסט, אבל מה הסתרתי לכם את הטקסט הזה?
בואו תנחשו לא, לא אומר לכם כן. באיזו סיטואציה בכלל אתם נתקלים בבעיה הזאת אז?
והסיבה שהבעיה הזאת היא שהשביתה למידה הזאתי היא בעיה משונה.
זה כי מראש בשנה מהפעמים הקודמות שדיברנו עליהם,
נכון שעשינו פרט speech staging או language מודלינג או או ני דן אתה תראה קובי, אנחנו לא באמת מתעניינים בבעיה הזאת.
אנחנו משתמשים בבעיה הזאת. כאו גזילת ההשכלה אנחנו משתמשים בעצם אנחנו מנסים לפתור בעיה שהיא בעיה שבכלל לא מעניינת אותנו בשום רמה.
אנחנו לא הולכים לנסות באמת לעשות אותה. אנחנו לא נריץ אותה על טס דאטה.
אין בזה שום טעם. זה לא המטרה שלה, כל המטרה שלה.
היא בעצם שכבה Product כתוצר לוואי של תהליך הלמידה.
אנחנו מקווים ללמוד ייצוגים טובים של המילה.
כן, זה בעצם המהלך. כן? כן, בבקשה.
אתה כאילו רק מסתכל על המרחב, על הטפטים של הרשת.
תכף נגיע לזה. תכף נגיע לזה. כאילו בשקופית הקודמת זה היה יהודי.
זה לא. אתה מאמן בעצם את הרשת עצמך.
לא שזה כן מקבל את המילים השכנות, אבל אחר כך כל מה שאתה מסתכל עליו כדי לעשות את הפלסטינים שאמרת על זה.
רק אתה מסתכל על זה. אתם תראו משהו כזה.
כן, זה שקופית הבאה. אבל כן, תכף אני. כן.
למה לא לבחון אותה למתן פלסטין שלנו עכשיו?
כאילו? בעצם לבחון את הגידול שיוצא לנו?
על מה לבחון אותו? סתם לקחת את חלקי הדיבר?
או בדיוק לא? אז אתה צודק, אבל אנחנו תכף נדבר גם על זה.
זה בדיוק מה שנקרא, אבל יועצי אקס טרנזיט. כן, כי בעצם אתה אומר אני לא באמת רוצה לבחון את זה.
התחזית כי מראש זה לא עניין אותי. כן, לא נכון, זה קיים, אבל זה שונה מאשר נגיד Parts of speech שתיים שלכאורה אתה למדת אותה כי היה לך איזשהו עניין.
כן בדיוק כן. בהמשך הסרט זכינו גם לכפות על הממסד להאשים את טריינינג לוס שלנו לפי כאילו במבנה של ליגת בייסבול, כאילו לדרוש איזשהם תכונות מסוימות שלא.
כן כן, גם זה לפעמים עושים. כן, זה גם זה איזשהו רעיון שנגיד למשל, או אולי יש לך איזושהי תכונה מבנית של המרחב, ואתה רוצה להכניס אותה כרגע לאריזה ציה?
או אולי יש לך מילון? ואתה אומר אוקיי, המילון הזה לא מושלם, אבל בכל זאת יש בו איזשהו ערך.
אז אתה מוסיף איזושהי רגולרי והציע שדואגת שלפחות המידע שכתוב במילון יהיה פחות או יותר יישמר או יש.
כל כן. יש כל מיני רעיונות כאלה, אבל כאילו זה הצורה הכי בסיסית.
כן. ובאמת עכשיו השאלה אז מה אנחנו עושים עם זה? אז אז כן, אז מה שהרבה פעמים עושים עם זה פשוט אומרים אוקיי, אם הרשת שלי כן,
שערכתי את דבליו ודאבל מותג בצורה כזאת שהצלחתי כמה שיותר להעלות את ההסתברות של טריינינג דאטה כן או בעצם של הקורפוסים.
אז מה שזה אומר זה שבאיזה שהיא צורה יצרתי פה התפלגות שהיא דומה להתפלגות האמיתית.
כן, או לפחות ההתפלגות האמפירית האמיתית. כן ההתפלגות של הסנפיר.
אז מה? אז מה שזה אומר זה שבעצם אני עכשיו יכול לחשוב אולי על ההבדל ופה כן על ההבדלים על אקטיבציה בהינתן layer בתור הייצוג של המילה.
אז דרך אחת לעשות את זה זה באמת בדיוק זאת. לקחת פשוט לכל מילה את השורה שמתאימה לה בדאבל U ולהגיד זה עם Padding שני.
כן אחרי זה יש איזשהו דאבליו טאג שעושה לדיקור דינג להתפלגות אמיתית.
אבל זה לא מעניין אותי, כי אם יש מטריצה אחת קבועה שעושה דיקור דינג לכל אם בג'ינס שלי למשהו שהוא התפלגות אמיתית,
אז איכשהו כל האינפורמציה שאני צריך נמצאת כבר בהתפלגות לפני הדיכאון.
כן, אז. בסדר זה.
זה רעיון אחד, רעיון שאני אומר חבל לוותר על דאבליו.
גם הוא מכיל אינפורמציה משמעותית. כן, בעצם אני אומר כן.
מה דאבליו תג אומר דאבליו תג אומר יש לי עכשיו עמודה לכל מילה, שכשאני מכפיל את העמודה הרלוונטית בשורה הרלוונטית, מכפלה סקלרית אני מקבל בעצם את האזכור.
כן, כמה הם associated אחד עם השני, אז אולי גם לזה יש ערך.
אז מה שלפעמים עושים זה לוקחים. נגיד למשל גם את האאוטפיטים דינג ומשלשלים את זה.
האינפוט היברידי נגיד אם לא אכפת לכם להגדיל את המימד לשתיהן, אז כבר עושים את זה, או לפעמים מחברים אותם או כל מיני דברים,
ונראה לי עדיין הגישה הכי פופולרית זה פשוט לקחת את אינפו טיים בילדינג ולהגיד האינפורמציה כבר נמצאת שם.
ואם וזה קצת מתקשר בעצם לשקף הבא שידבר על הצורה שמשתמשים בהם.
כן, אז הצורה שמשתמשים בה עם Things הרבה פעמים זה פשוט כתחליף לוואן טוק Terms שדיברנו עליהם.
נכון, אמרנו שהרבה פעמים שאנחנו משתמשים ברשתות אנחנו צריכים בעצם לקחת את הסיגנל שהוא סיגנל דיסקרטי.
בדרך כלל. במקרה של NLP נכון, מילים טקסט ולהפוך אותו לרשת צריכה לווקטור, למטריצה, ל טנזור למשהו כזה.
אז איך אנחנו עושים את זה? אם אפשר לעשות one shot וקטור או למנות וקטור זה צורה די בזבזנית?
כן, כי זה משהו במימד נורא גבוה אז ואומרת ספר סי.
אז אולי מה שאפשר לעשות זה לתת לרשת קצת Interactive בייס לקודד את זה במימד יותר נמוך עם הורוד עם איקס, או אם יש לי טקסט.
לפעמים לוקחים את כל המילים בטקסט ועושים להם ממוצע.
כן, לבוא יודעים, זה סוג של בגבוה הרץ. כן, רק בגובה.
רואה את זה על וקטורים בגובה כאלה? כן, אז לפעמים גם עושים כאלה.
ועכשיו אפשר להבין למה. אולי אפשר להגיד שהעידן פרזנטציה הישן זה אלה הם באמת קידוד הגיוני למילה.
כי בעצם מה? מה הרציונל? אמרנו? אימצנו את הרשת ככה שהיא אתם הרי present nation.
זה חי. כופלים אותם בדבליו פריים. נכון, הם נותנים משהו שהוא עד כדי soft.
מקס דומה להתפלגות. ככה אימנו את הרשת.
אוקיי, ואז אנחנו אומרים בוא נשכח את דבליו טג.
הוא לא מעניין אותנו יותר ונשכח מהסוף. מקס ניקח רק את מה שכתוב כאן.
כן, נשכח, מעט קודר כן, ומה שאחרי זה מה דבליו תג כפולה דבליו תג ואחריו עשו מורכב עם סופט מקס שבעצם מוציא לנו התפלגו.
וכאילו הרציונל אומר שבסדר א.
לא בטוח שאני רוצה בדיוק את ההתפלגות. אולי אני רוצה משהו אחר, אז אני לאו דווקא רוצה את הדיקור יותר הזה.
אולי יהיה לדיקור דרך אחר ושתיים, אפילו אם הייתי רוצה את הדיקור דרך הזה שהרשת כבר תלמד אותו.
כן, זאת אומרת בוא ניתן לרשת, בעצם בוא ניתן.
הרשת בעצמה כבר יכולה לקבל את האינפוט על Present הישן, ואם נורא חשוב לה לשחזר את ההתפלגות האמיתית או קואורדינטות או חלק ממנה,
אז שתלמד פה את המטריה וכי מספיק פעמים היא תלמד את דאבליו פריים ותכנס אליו.
זאת אומרת אין טעם לקודד אותו ישירות שהרשת כבר תמצא אותו ובכלל לא בטוח שהיא תרצה למצוא אותו,
כי אולי היא בכלל לא מתעניינת בהתפלגות אלא באיזושהי נגזרת שלה או לא יודע.
כמובן, זה הכל נפנופי ידיים. כן, כמו תמיד ברשתות נוירונים או כמעט הוי בסדר.
אז כן, אז באמת משתמשים הרבה מאוד פעמים בוועדים או בתור פרזנטציה של מילים בודדות או עושים ממוצע ואז מן סוג של פר גבוה את זה בפאזל תישן.
הרבה פעמים משתמשים בהם רק כי נשאל איזה אישר.
כן, זאת אומרת אומרים אוקיי, תשמעו, יש לי פה עוד דובק.
זה נראה לי סקיפ גם כן. זה נראה לי בסדר.
זה ייתן לי איזשהו ניחוש ראשוני, אבל כבר כשהרשת מתאמנת אני מרשה לה לשנות את זה.
אני לא עושה את זה. For זן כן, אני נותן לשנות, כי אולי זה לא בדיוק מה שהיא צריכה.
היא צריכה משהו קצת זה. אז גם את זה הרבה פעמים משתמשים.
יצא לכם לדבר קצת על ימי ששמרתי מי שהיה לי Seasons לרשתות או בכלל תמיד התחלתם רנדומלית וזה אוקיי, אז אנחנו נדבר בהמשך הקורס.
נראה שזה אחד הדברים הכי פופולריים איכשהו ב NLP של השנים האחרונות.
העניין הזה ששמרתי מי שלי זה אוקיי, כי בגלל שאלה בעיות מאוד לא קמורות כפי שזה, אני מניח שלמדתם באימייל.
נכון שיש להם המון, מקסימום מגיעים לזה. אז בעצם נקודת ההתחלה מאוד משפיעה על המקום שאליו הם התכנסו, ולכן יש טעם בלעשות סדר.
אז גם את זה לפעמים עושים. וגם זה לפעמים עושים ובאמת הרבה פעמים הדרך לעשות להם אבל.
אמציה זה באמת באיזושהי צורה. אקסטרים זית כן, באיזושהי צורה אקסטרים זית.
כי כלומר על ידי איזשהו Down Stream Application שבו נשתמש בהם.
כי לעבוד עם בייג'ינג זה הם סך הכל כן אמצעי הם לא מטרה בפני עצמה.
לקראת סוף הקורס אנחנו נדבר גם על הנושא של קונטקסט שאולי כן.
שבעצם הרעיון שם הוא שאחד החסרונות הגדולים של הגישה הזאת, כמו סקייפ,
גם זה שבעצם כל המופעים של Wait for מסוים כן של צורה מסוימת, תמיד יקבלו את אותו הווקטור.
נכון, לא תלוי רק בצורה שהמילה כתובה, כלומר dog כחלק מהות Dog ודוב כחלק מיתוג פיט ודוב כחלק מזה, אז פשוט אומר כלב.
כל מיני דברים שונים ומשונים כולם יקבלו בדיוק את אותו וקטור.
אבל הרבה פעמים אפשר מאוד מהר להבין משאר המילים במשפט שנגיד אם כתוב לפני זה אות שכנראה לא מדובר בדוגמה כללי שהוא חלק מהודו,
אז כאילו זה את נגיד אבל דוגמה קיצונית כן, אבל הרבה פעמים יש בשאר המילים במשפט הרבה מאוד רמזים שבעצם עושים עוד ויועציה או כאן טקסטואלי.
זה ציה שבעצם גורמים לפיצ'ר עם אחרים להיות יותר חשובים לפיצ'ר מסוימים, להיות יותר חשובים מאחרים והדברים האלה לא נותנים את זה.
כן, זה בגלל זה. זה נקרא Non כאן טקסט שולי ואני באמת לקראת סוף הקורס.
אנחנו נדבר על קונטקסט שונה בין אינדקס שהם בעצם משלימים את הפער הזה, ואיכשהו לוקחים בחשבון גם את שאר המילים שנמצאות במשפט כדרך לייצג.
המילה האחרונה שרציתי להגיד בהקשר הזה זה ש.
וזה אולי איזושהי הערה לגבי לגבי לקסיקון סמנטיקה שבעצם אידאלית מה שמה שאנחנו מקודדים כאן.
זה בהנחה שהדברים האלה עובדים, זה באמת איזשהו סוג של סופרפוזיציה,
כן או איזשהו סוג של מיצוע של כל ההקשרים השונים, כל המובנים השונים, כל התכונות השונות שמילה מופיעה בהם.
כן, כי ככה עבדנו בעצם.
בסופו של דבר ההתפלגות שלנו כפי שהגדרנו אותה, היא בסוף הייתה פשוט לקחת את כל המופעים של המילה נכון ולכל אחד מהם להסתכל מה השכנים,
לסחוב את השדות, לאכול אגרגציה ביחד, כך שלא יישאר לי שום דבר שמרמז לי מאיפה הגיע איזה ספירה.
כן, זה הכל פשוט עובר.
נכנס איזה סל אחד גדול של כל ההקשרים השונים וככה אני מקבל וקטור שהוא בעצם חיבור או מיצוע או איזשהו ממוצע משוקלל כנראה של כל הגוונים וההקשרים השונים.
עכשיו זה גם בעייתי מבחינת מובנים של מילים כמו שאמרנו קודם, אבל אתם לא מסתכלים על מובן ספציפי.
כנראה שהייתם רוצים להתמקד בהקשר מסוים בטחוניות מסוימות ולא אחרות.
כן, אז אז לדוגמה, תקחו את המילה נגיד דג.
אוקיי, אז המילה דג יכולה להופיע בכל מיני הקשרים.
יש לה ברמה הבסיסית היא יש דיסה בקרואטיה.
נכון? כי דג יכול להיות פועל ויכול להיות שם עצם נכון ואני מניע ויכול להיות טוב, תלוי איך כותבים אותו.
אני לא יודע. גרף מכוון, חסר מעגלים או משהו כזה, אבל בסופו של דבר, אפילו אם אתם מסתכלים על מובן מסוים של דג, נגיד הדג הזה ששוחה בים וכאלה,
אז הוא מופיע לכל הפחות בשני קשרים שבהם תכוניות מאוד שונות שלו באות לידי ביטוי אחת מהם כחלק מן תבשיל.
והשני, למשל כחיה הימית או משהו כזה עכשיו.
למרות שמדובר על אותה אישות. זאת אומרת, זה לא באמת מובנים, שונים במובן שזה לא יודע כמו בר.
נכון שאני שותה בו אלכוהול ובר כמו תבואה.
כן, שניהם מדברים על דג, על אותה חיה. כן, אבל תחשבו על מה מהם התכונות הרלוונטיות שלו.
לא יודע, אולי בתור תבשיל או חלק מהתבשיל דרגת השומניות, כמות העצמות לא יודע, התבלינים שהולכים איתו טוב.
יין שכדאי לשתות כמלווה משהו כזה כן.
הדברים האלה לא נורא רלוונטיים בהיותו חיה ימית.
אני חושב נכון, לפחות קשה לי לחשוב אם הם לא תופסים איזשהו מקום מאוד מרכזי.
ולכן בהקשר מסוים שבו אתם מדברים, נגיד על דג המחמד שלכם או על דג שראיתם שיצאתם למסע צלילה.
כן, זה לא יהיה אותם המילים, זה לא יהיה אותם ההקשרים,
זה לא יהיה אותם פיצ'רים סמנטיים והיינו רוצים גם את הדבר הזה איכשהו לייצג או איכשהו להיות מסוגלים בעצם לקבל מידע עליו.
כן, הקונטקסט שבו הוא מופיע והתכונות שרלוונטיות לאותו קונטקסט.
אז במובן הזה, הנון קונטקסט שאולי סמואל עם Things שאנחנו מדברים עליהם כמו הסקייפ,
גם הוא Deficiency כאילו לוקה הוא לוקה כאילו בעצם בצורה יותר עמוקה אפילו.
מהמובן הזה, שבמובנים שונים של אותה מילה עוברים איזשהו אגרגציה ביחד, אלא הוא גם חסר לו את הגמישות שבעצם תדע לשקף את הפיצ'רים הרלוונטיים בהקשר מסוים.
אוקיי, אז זה היה דיון שלנו על וויד עם דיינס. יש לנו ממש עוד כמה דקות, אז אני לא אתחיל כבר נושא חדש של שבוע הבא.
אנחנו נדבר על ניתוח של מבנה תלויות אוטומטי, כלומר בדיוק הדיפרנציאלי Structure הזה שראינו קודם.
איך אנחנו מסוגלים לייצר אותם בצורה אוטומטית, ולקראת סוף השיעור גם מקשר את הדיון הזה לדיון על וויד עם בדאנס,
ונראה שהדברים מתחילים להתקשר, אבל שהם גם שונים.
כן, ומשם נמשיך הלאה. לנשים יותר מתקדמים כמו הטרנספורמר וכאילו NLP כפי שיותר נחווה.
שש שבע, שמונה שנים האחרונות. אוקיי.
להתראות. אין לי שאלה לגבי הסיבות שבגללן בן 25 דווקא לא מנסה לשנות רופא.
התערבות רפואית. כן, במה שנקרא סייסטה אצלנו.
כן כן כן, אז בעבר הם היו יותר פופולארים.
באיזה מדור את האתר כבר מדורים? אני לא עוסק בלשנות מלאה אז אני לא כאן אבל אני לוקחת יותר גדולה.
אוקיי. את לא בטוחה בנעשה בחוגים? זה דו חוגי של כללי רוח ואז תוכלי לראות מה עושים עם העניין הזה.
כן. אז הסיבה לזה היא שבסופו של דבר זה מאוד.
זה נורא קל לעבוד איתם מהבחינה הזאת של.
שאת יודעת מה קודקודי את בעצם? את יודעת כמה פריטי קצב יש?
זאת אומרת לכל מילה את צריכה לכסות עם שורש. או לחילופין מהגרעין שממנו הציפייה כן וזה.
וזה בעצם קומבינטורית. מבנה הרבה יותר פשוט. בעצם את יכולה לחשוב על זה כסוג של פיצ'ר.
אומנם פיצ'ר שהוא פרמטר, אבל עדיין איזשהו פיצ'ר של מילה כמו הפרדת פיצ'ר.
אז יש לה party speech. יש לה את ההד world כאילו index שלהם הוא ויש לה label כאילו שזה סוג דפנסיבי ליישם ביניהם,
בעוד שאם היית עושה free structure אז יש שם כל מיני דברים שכאילו לא כל כך רצו להתעסק בהם.
יש לך למשל דברי יונאי א.
את לא יודעת כמה קודקודים יש לך בעץ הבריאות. ב.
יש לך הפעם under expression זז בך כאילו שנכון שמשהו מתפצל.
כאילו שנגיד למשל יש לי גם את שיורד למטה שאם רק לאחד כמה פעמים כן נגיד גם פה שהוא מכיל יחיד וזהו.
אז כאילו יש לך בעצם כאילו משהו עם גיל וגודל אחד, אז גם זה מוסיף עוד איזשהו אמ נכון?
כי עכשיו כי כאילו עכשיו לכאורה כל פעם שיש לך קודקוד את גם צריכה להחליט אם הוא מתחבר.
נגיד יש לך קודקוד שמתחת שהוא מכסה שתי מילים.
אוקיי, אז זה לא שרק יש לכם. אז לכאורה יש לך רק אפשרות אחת.
יכול להיות שפשוט מתחתיו יש שתי מילים, אבל בעצם לא, כי יכול להיות שאחד מהמילים האלה יהיה ישירות מתחתיו והשני יהיה.
השנייה תהיה עוד בקוד שמתחתיו יש עוד אחד. אז זה כאילו מוסיף עוד זה בגרסאות מסוימות שהשתמשו בהם.
היה גם את נל Elements שהם גם הפופולריים בבלשנות ואז זה בכלל סיוט.
כן, כי הצורך באיזשהו בכל מיני מקומות להחליט איפה לדחוף כל מיני String ים שבכלל לא כתובים בשום מקום.
ויצא כאילו מה שקרה זה שהפריט דיסקציה של הדברים האלה הייתה באיכות לא כל כך טובה וזה בעצם מאוד דירדר את הרמה, את האיכות בעצם של ה פאלס.
אז אמרנו נעבור למשהו אומנם פחות אינפורמטיבי, אבל מצד שני אנחנו יודעים רק מילה בלי אבסטרקטית.
אז זה יותר בעיה של איך להתייחס לזה מבחינת הקוד ופחות.
אנחנו לא מאמינים בתאוריה. הקוד והלמידה כן, אבל כן, אבל זה מבחינת תיאוריה של אנחנו חושבים.
זה יותר נכון. יכול להיות שבקרב חלק מהאנשים, אבל רוב האנשים שמתעסקים ב NLP היום בכלל.
אבל אפילו בתקופה שהייתה יותר עדנה, אני חושב לתיאוריה בלשנית בתחום עדיין היה מדובר במיעוט.
רוב האנשים לא באמת. אלא אם את חוזרת לשנת תחילת שנות ה 90.
נגיד שאז באמת זה היה יותר קונקרטי, שונה לגמרי.
זוכרת עד כמה זה היה 35 שנים האחרונות.
מדובר במירוץ שאני נמנעת. תודה רבה.
תודה. אני רק שאלה את אסף.
תודה על השאלות. מבחינת אני שוב אני אראה את זה בהקלטה וכאלה.
אבל מבחינת רק סיכום קצר של הנושא האחרון שהצגת אחרי השם של זה אני ממליץ, לא כאילו הנה לפני, גם עכשיו בתוך הוורידים בידיים.
גם המודל האחרון שהצגת, שבדיוק קראנו את האימון שלו וכן סקיפ גם כן בדיוק אז רק מבחינת הרעיון לראות אם אני מבין, אז אנחנו בעצם כאילו נותנים לזה.
נותנים לזה את הקלט באיקס האינפוט שלנו.
יש לנו טיימליין, יש לנו בסוף גם את ה output והנה האימון עצמו כאילו גם על ג'רביניו, כאילו האימון עצמו אנחנו מעדכנים,
מדברים, עובדים בניוטרל, אבל רק כאילו לפי האימג הספציפי זה לא סוחב את כולם כאילו כל סוג הוא אינסטנט.
אז כל גמילה והעלאת השיר זה כאילו טיימינג סמפל אחד כן נראה לי.
אני מנסה כאילו להקל קצת את הרעיון. כאילו מה זה רעיון קצת מוזר.
מה בדיוק ניסינו לעשות פה?
מה שניסינו לעשות זה בעצם ליצור, ללמוד עיצוב אפקטיבי, קומפקטי, דחוס משהו, כזה של אנטי שנקרא לו, של ההתפלגות של הקול של המאה עם מילים אחרות.
כן. ובזמן שעשינו זה בעצם עשינו בעת הדיקציה שבה אם אתן לך מילה ואתה צריך לנחש את המילה Dictionary, כן, ואם אתה עכשיו עושה אתה לא תצליח בזה באמת.
זה יכול להיות כל מילה. יש לה הרבה יותר אפשרויות.
כן, אבל הרעיון הוא שככל שתצליח בזה יותר, זה אומר שקודם כל בצורה יותר טובה את ההתפלגות האמיתית של המילה.
ובסוף אנחנו לוקחים את האם. כאילו תאים פוטו תות פה.
כאילו איך זה?
ואז זה כבר עניין שרירותי, כאילו של בדרך כלל לוקחים לפחות פה תבנית, אבל לפעמים נגיד משרשרת אליו את האאוטפיטים או ממציאים ביניהם או משהו כזה.
אבל אין כאן תיאור יותר מדי, כאילו אני פשוט מנסה להבין.
אני הכנסתי וקטור של מילים. בעצם יש לי כל נעשתה על הרשת מאות וקטור.
אוקיי, וקיבלת וקטור על התפלגות.
אחרי שהפרסומת הבאה עבור מילה נתונה, לא האינפוט או מילה נתונה וההודעות או התפלגות וההודעות, ואפשר לראות שזה בעצם הייצוג.
היכן הם בדיוק של המילה נתונה בדיוק ההתפלגות הזאת אומרת לך מה ההסתברות לכל שכן להיות כל שחי נכון?
שאנחנו מגדירים שכן כמילה אחת, נגיד כמילה שמופיעה באותו משפט כמילה שמופיעה בכל משפט.
זה גם בחירה שרירותית. אתה יכול לבחור, נגיד זה אפשרויות פופולריות או יותר פופולרי.
זה יכלול פלוס מינוס שבע מילים. כן.
ועכשיו עברית. ועכשיו אתה אומר.
אם הצלחתי לקודד וצורן, אם הצלחתי להוריד את הטעמים, להרוס או להגדיל את הליכוד, אז בעצם הצלחתי לייצר ייצוג קומפקטי של ההתפלגות שלנו.
כן. ועכשיו אני פשוט השמש. בעצם אני אשתמש בתוצר הלוואי של התהליך הפרטי קציר הזה.
כדי לקבל Wedding. בעצם אני אומר הרשת כדי לפתור את הבעיה, למדה איזשהו עיצוב שיעזור לה לחזור.
אז אני אקח את העיצוב הזה בתור נציג שלנו, כי זה אומר שאתה לא יכול להסתפק רק בעין אחת output או שלפחות המסווגות שאני כותב בסוף,
כי אני לא זוכר אם אמרת את זה עכשיו או שזה עתה שמישהו זרק, זה גם מזכיר לי זה משהו.
אתה לא יכול. כאילו אמרת שאני צריך לפחות את ה input או משהו כזה, או שאתה משלשל את האינפוט ואת המפות.
וזה היה לי פה אתמול האלה. לא כי השאלה איזה תוצר לוואי של האימון אתה לוקח בסוף?
אני רוצה כאילו כמובן שבסוף אני יכול לתת output או שאני פשוט לוקח את המשקולות ומשקולות.
בסוף אני עושה product על סמך האינפוט המשקולות לא סליחה output עם בילדינג ואין פוטים.
אוקיי זה אני מבין מה לא ברור עכשיו גם כשאני מדבר על עם בילדינג אני מדבר על המשקולות.
אוקיי, רק על המשקל. אוקיי. אז אם פוטין בייג'ינג זה פשוט משקולות של שורה מתאימה בידיו.
אוקיי, והלימודים בייג'ינג זה מה שאני קורא לך. ככה אני קורא לעבודות של הילד קונטקסט תרבותי באתר מיצג.
אוקיי. אז מה שאני אומר זה שהמשכורות שהרשת למדה אפשר לחשוב עליהן כייצוג של המילה ייצוג של עצמנו.
כן, כי זה מה שהרשת מוכנה לעשות. כן. אתה נגיד מכיר בביזנס שעושים surgical click ואז לוקחים את העיצוב של האמת שאתה השכבה לפני אחרונה.
יצא לך להיתקל בזה כי לא נעים לסרב? זה נשמע מוכר, אבל כאילו זה רעיון דומה שקיבלת, אומר.
אימנתי רשת, יודעת להבחין בין ג'ירפה לפיל, זברה להתאמה.
אז עכשיו אני אומר אז אני אקח את העיצוב שלה, את העיצוב של התמונה.
כי אם הוא לא יהיה ייצוג טוב של התמונה אז היא לא הייתה יכולה לחזור.
זה מן רעיון דומה. אז אתה אוקיי, אז אתה כאילו אומר מבחינת האם אנחנו בסוף?
האם אנחנו לוקחים רק את האינפוט? קודים או גם כן, גם את דבליו, גם את המבטא, רק את הפרמטרים של דבליו גם.
ובסוף זה עוזר לנו להגיע כאילו לאן קואוצ'ינג שאנחנו רוצים פה בעצם כן לאיזשהו ייצוג דחוס שאתה מקווה שהוא משקף פיצ'רים יותר אבסטרקטיים.
וזה כאילו זה סטנדרט. זה משהו שתמיד עושים עכשיו הוא מאוד נפוץ, מאוד נפוץ.
גם אם לא ספציפית סקייפ גם אז משהו אחר כן. כאילו שהאפשרויות שלנו זה או זה או להתחיל לדבר על דברים הרבה יותר בסיסיים כמו שאמרת בהתחלה כמו
תדירויות וכאן כן אומרת לעשות כל מיני החלקות ויש וכל מיני דברים כאלה שזה השיטות שפעם נתתי לעצמי.
האם זה יכול איכשהו להתחבר או אפשר לעשות במקום זה כאילו משהו עם טוב, כי חשבתי אוקיי, זה כאילו כן הגיוני לי לקשר בין מילים שנמצאות באותו משפט.
אבל אולי אני כאילו אני חושב כאילו על זה שיש לי עכשיו חתול ויש לי כלב,
ואולי אני פשוט אחליף עכשיו את המשפט אני אוציא את החתול מהמשפט ואני אכניס לשם את הכלב או לא יודע, אז אני איכשהו יסתכל גם על מה שאמרת.
על מילים אחרות במשפט. גם אני אוודא שהמילים עצמן הם אותו חלק, דיבר כאילו או שאני אוהב.
אפשר לעשות קודם תצפית שתי מילים ואז להתייחס למילים שכתבת אותו דבר והייתה תצפית שחר כמילה שונה,
ולכל אחת יחשב את ההתפלגות משלה, כי אפשר לעשות את זה או כל מיני דרכים אחרות לחלק את המילים, את הטקסטים.
אבל אנחנו נלמד על שיטה יותר כללית וחזקה בהמשך שנקראת קונטקסט שהולך להיות, שזה מצריך משהו מאוד בטרנספורמציה מתמדת.
מגיעים לזה שבוע הבא. הוא נראה לי עוד שבוע, עוד שבועיים.
טוב תודה רבה. שיעורים אנחנו עכשיו בשבוע 7.
זה עבר מהר מדי שבוע ויש בקיצור גם שבוע.
אז זה 12. כן יש עוד חמישה שם ובסוף גם שמעתי שאמרו איזה משהו שיהיה איזה מיקוד בקשר.
כן לא הבנתי עוד מה זה, אבל כן יש משהו כזה.
אבל אמרתי מה אני צריכה לעשות? ואמרנו חמישה תרגילים בקורס הזה?
כן. תודה רבה. שלום רב!
לפני. שלושה חודשים.
זוהי. בשקט.
בשקט כמעט ורק המחשבה.
חצי. לא.
בכל פעם שניסינו. יש משפט.
פשוט. מנצלת את זה שהמשחק הזה מסכן.
בין השאר מעמידה. פנים ביום אחד כי המעבדה לא תגיד הגעתי בסוף כדי לא.
יום. אמרתי אני לעצמי.
אוהבת. אתה.
התמונה בכל, אבל לא. כל הכבוד לך!
מה זה? אז רגע.
קרה. זה היה.